[Music]
wonder woman
[Music]
ready one two three do it don't go
[Music]
so it doesn't go all the way
[Music]
swear to god this is like
[Music]
what is it
oh out of it okay do you want to try one
more let me
just go back to the top right
[Music]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
okay
diane i've got some bad news treat me
like
be giovanni be
[Music]
you truly delight me we just laughing
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah of course the hugh vernon
washington series aren't going to win
any prizes for you
you can't possibly understand him oh i
can't possibly understand
oh my god are you okay
[Music]
style smile what we got forgotten
who would wear it let's try something
else i'm not even wearing underwear
that's how comfortable these pants are
really yeah
i think it's going to draw too much
[Music]
my time listening intently i'm listening
intently
where you're doing smelly pants i am
so invested in this
okay i'll present you guys to the twins
as the world turns okay gal will giggle
at the air
i'm ready
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
this
[Music]
you don't see what he's doing to me not
doing it
ready
okay wait a second
just a second
[Music]
[Laughter]
honestly
[Laughter]
good
ready um
[Music]
oh my god these plans are so big
what for all the place hey steve this
way
oh man i love flampland
oh my blood
[Music]
just farted i heard that
[Music]
cheers
[Music]